Hey there, Will Arnett here from SmartList. It's the podcast where Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, and I interview somebody. Two of us don't know who that person is because one of us has brought on a surprise guest. That's the whole conceit. I wish I could describe it better, but I'm not that smart. So it's SmartList, and it's starting now. Smart. Smart.
大家好，我是来自《SmartList》的威尔·阿奈特。这是一个由杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海耶斯和我共同主持的播客，我们会采访嘉宾。我们其中两人不知道嘉宾是谁，因为另外一人会带来一位惊喜嘉宾。这就是节目的全部构思。我希望能描述得更好一些，但我没那么聪明。所以这就是《SmartList》，现在开始。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Hey, are we rolling? Are we doing this?
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。嘿，我们开始录了吗？我们要开始了吗？
We're already podcasting. That's the great thing about podcasting. Sometimes you're just doing it and you don't even know. What about my tasty flair of God on my... Oh yeah, I saw that. Did you have JJ Abrams over? Yeah, I did. Hey, did you guys see that nexium thing, that documentary called The Vow?
我们已经在录播客了。这就是播客的妙处。有时候你已经在做了，甚至自己都不知道。我那关于上帝的美味天赋怎么样……哦对了，我看到了。你请了J·J·艾布拉姆斯吗？是的，我请了。嘿，你们看到那个Nexium的东西了吗，就是那部叫《誓言》的纪录片？
Nexium is a little bit more for... Yeah, like if you have heartburn. Heartburn or loose stools. There's an entire documentary about... Loose stools and heartburn. Was I happy when my doctor said nexium? Like that kind of thing? It was that cult thing.
Nexium更多是用于……对，就像如果你有胃灼热的话。胃灼热或大便稀溏。有一部完整的纪录片是关于……大便稀溏和胃灼热的。我医生说Nexium的时候我高兴吗？类似那种？那是关于那个邪教的。
I know what you mean. I can't believe I haven't been back yet. It's so wild. I gotta say, and I mean this, and Sean, you know how much I love you and I've loved you for a long time. But... I feel like you could get caught up in a cult. Who says I'm not?
我明白你的意思。真不敢相信我还没回去看。太疯狂了。我得说，我是认真的，肖恩，你知道我有多爱你，而且我爱你很久了。但是……我觉得你可能会陷入邪教。谁说我没有？
That's true. I feel like you could just drift away. By the way, this guy said... Okay, so wait, I gotta tell you. So the guy, the crazy sexual predator guy who runs the whole thing. Sounds like a great guy. Yeah, he sounds amazing. Women, but anyway. It's so fucked up, man.
那倒是。我觉得你可能会随波逐流。顺便说一下，这家伙说……好吧，等等，我得告诉你。所以那个家伙，那个经营整个组织的疯狂性掠夺者。听起来是个好人。是的，他听起来很棒。女人，但不管怎样。这太他妈糟糕了，伙计。
It's really fucked up. But it's really fascinating that people can get sucked into that cult like that. I'm gonna be honest with you. I saw that thing, you and I, you asked me about that the other day. We were FaceTiming on a personal FaceTime. And I... Did I ask you about the vow? About, yeah.
这真的很糟糕。但人们能那样被吸入邪教真的很令人着迷。老实说，我看了那个东西，你和我，你前几天问过我。我们在进行私人FaceTime通话。我……我问过你关于《誓言》的事吗？关于，是的。
And I thought, I don't... It just seems too dark for me. I mean, as much as I like to... I can't take that kind of stuff. Things is like, I'm fascinated by how somebody can believe that. Like, what point did you go? Can I get that? Yeah, that makes sense to me.
我想，我不……这对我来说似乎太黑暗了。我是说，尽管我喜欢……我受不了那种东西。事情是这样的，我很着迷于某人怎么会相信那个。就像，你在哪一点开始觉得？我可以接受那个？是的，那对我来说说得通。
We're getting very close to a religious conversation, which I don't think would end well. No. And also we have a really, really great guest today that I'm excited to... Pope John Paul, no? No, it's... Could you imagine if we got...
我们快要进行宗教对话了，我觉得这不会有什么好结果。不。而且我们今天有一位非常、非常棒的嘉宾，我很兴奋能……教皇约翰·保罗，不？不，是……你能想象如果我们请到了……
Will's just walking. How great would it be if one of us was like, the Pope is here. That would never... And he still has the hat on and everything. Here comes Will's crappy intro. Let's hear it.
威尔只是在走来走去。如果我们要么其中一人说，教皇来了，那该多好。那永远不会……而且他还戴着帽子什么的。威尔糟糕的开场白来了。让我们听听。
First of all, it's not going to be flattering. Speaking of crappy intros, I've heard some... I don't even try. I listen to the podcast. You don't try at all. Well, I don't want to insult the guest by trying to craft some big flowery thing. Trying to put any work into it? Yeah, this isn't for work.
首先，这不会是什么好话。说到糟糕的开场白，我听过一些……我甚至都不尝试。我听播客。你根本没尝试。好吧，我不想通过试图编造一些华丽的东西来侮辱嘉宾。试图在上面下功夫？是的，这不是为了工作。
This is just chat and giggle. Chat and giggle. Well, I am going to say this. Our special guest today is a really, really formidable person. He has accomplished so much in what I think is a pretty small amount of time.
这只是聊天和傻笑。聊天和傻笑。好吧，我要说的是。我们今天的特别嘉宾是一个非常、非常了不起的人。他在我认为相当短的时间内取得了如此多的成就。
This is a guy who... That's Webster. Really started a sort of square one, worked in a bunch of restaurants, then started his own restaurant, then started multiple restaurants and businesses, then started a very popular TV show
这是一个……那是韦伯斯特。真正从零开始，在很多餐馆工作过，然后开了自己的餐馆，然后开了多家餐馆和企业，然后开了一个非常受欢迎的电视节目
on PBS called Mind of a Chef, and then did his documentary series about food called Ugly Delicious. I've seen Ugly Delicious. He started Momofuku. Oh, my gosh. All those restaurants started in New York
在PBS上叫《厨师的思维》，然后做了关于食物的纪录片系列叫《丑陋的美味》。我看过《丑陋的美味》。他创办了Momofuku。哦，天哪。所有那些餐馆都是在纽约开的
and then Sydney and Toronto and Tokyo and Los Angeles and everywhere. God, he sounds loaded. I just want to get him in here so we can start talk to him. Our guest today... Unless he's left. ...is Mr. David Chang. Oh, yeah!
然后是悉尼、多伦多、东京、洛杉矶和世界各地。天哪，他听起来很有钱。我只想让他进来，这样我们就可以开始和他谈话了。我们今天的嘉宾……除非他走了。……是戴维·张先生。哦，耶！
David Chang, look at him go. I'd love it if you were just chewing when we saw you. What a pleasure. I'm so psyched you're here, David. What an honor. Now, first of all, David, why? Listen, it's that voice. His voice is just so soothing.
戴维·张，看他来了。如果你进来时正在咀嚼，我会很喜欢。真是荣幸。我很高兴你来了，戴维。真是荣幸。现在，首先，戴维，为什么？听着，就是那个声音。他的声音太令人舒心了。
I'll do anything. I'm going to Momofuku. You know what I mean? I'm just saying when you walk in. Wait, is that a new thing at the hostess table? I'm just saying when you walk in, if you walked in and you heard that, and you thought like, uh... Activated when the door opens.
我什么都愿意做。我要去Momofuku。你知道我的意思吗？我只是说当你走进去的时候。等等，接待台有新东西吗？我只是说当你走进去的时候，如果你走进去听到了那个，你会觉得，呃……门打开时激活。
A server will be by to take your order soon. Relax. Okay. I'd be like, I'm relaxed. And a little horny. Maybe a little bit. I'd be like, is this a fuck restaurant? What's going on? I've actually seen Ugly Delicious.
服务员很快就会来为您点餐。放松。好的。我会觉得，我很放松。还有点兴奋。也许有一点。我会觉得，这是个操蛋的餐馆吗？怎么回事？我其实看过《丑陋的美味》。
It's a great show, and you're amazing on it. I'm a big fan. Thank you. I need to go eat at your restaurant in Los Angeles. Now, Major Domo is the one that's not called Momofuku. Yeah, that's right. Major Domo. And the first time I went to Momofuku in New York, I went with our friend, David Cross,
那是个很棒的节目，你在里面很棒。我是你的忠实粉丝。谢谢。我得去你在洛杉矶的餐馆吃顿饭。现在，Major Domo是那个不叫Momofuku的餐馆。是的，没错。Major Domo。我第一次去纽约的Momofuku时，是和我们的朋友戴维·克罗斯一起去的，
years ago. You probably know David. Yeah, longtime supporter. I do. We did a show together, Will. Sorry, I'm talking to David, Jason. It was a cheap, easy joke. And he introduced me to the wonderful world of
几年前。你可能认识戴维。是的，长期支持者。我认识。我们一起做过节目，威尔。抱歉，我在和戴维说话，杰森。那是个廉价、简单的笑话。他把我带进了美妙的
your culinary delights. But you've done so much. It is hard to try to intro you because you are your... You're super young, right? Yeah, that's what I mean. Look at the guy. I'm 43 this summer. I don't feel young.
你的烹饪乐趣世界。但你做了这么多。很难尝试介绍你，因为你是你的……你超级年轻，对吧？是的，这就是我的意思。看看这家伙。我今年夏天43岁。我不觉得年轻。
Wow. Jesus, that is old. Yeah, but all the... No, no, no. Don't make him feel bad. Only a 51-year-old can say that. Wait, when you open restaurant after restaurant, aren't you just like, isn't it just like a big, huge roll of the dice? Are you just like... Yes, it is.
哇。天哪，那太老了。是的，但所有……不，不，不。别让他感觉不好。只有51岁的人才能那样说。等等，当你一家接一家地开餐馆时，你不觉得这就像一场巨大的赌博吗？你只是……是的，确实是。
Every time I finish opening a restaurant, I tell myself, I'm never going to do that again. Ever. I'm sure. But I would assume, obviously, the more you do, the longer you're around, the more your clientele becomes expanded and the openings become less risky, right?
每次我开完一家餐馆，我都告诉自己，我再也不会那样做了。永远。我肯定。但我会假设，显然，你做得越多，你待的时间越长，你的客户群就越扩大，开业的风险就越小，对吧？
And your brand is bigger, yeah. Yes and no. I mean, in some ways, they don't want us to do anything new, but they also want us to do something new. So you got to find that fine line of pushing the envelope but keeping it comfortable for everybody. Like a rock band. So you started, you worked at...
而且你的品牌更大了，是的。既是也不是。我是说，在某些方面，他们不希望我们做任何新的事情，但他们也希望我们做一些新的事情。所以你必须找到那个在推动界限和保持每个人舒适之间的微妙平衡。就像摇滚乐队。所以你开始，你在……工作
I think I've got this right. You worked in a bunch of restaurants and you worked... You worked for Tom Glicchio for a while at his restaurant. Top chef. Yeah, of top chef fame and you kind of bounced around. You worked at a bunch of different places. You decided I'm going to open my own shop
我想我没记错。你在很多餐馆工作过，而且你……你在汤姆·克里奇奥的餐馆为他工作过一段时间。顶级厨师。是的，顶级厨师的名声，你有点到处跳槽。你在很多不同的地方工作过。你决定我要开自己的店
because to Sean's point, it's a big risk, it takes a lot of guts. What were those conversations like to go, I'm going to do this? Yeah. Well, truthfully, the main reason I decided to open up my own restaurant is I was never going to have my own restaurant
因为按照肖恩的观点，这是一个巨大的风险，需要很大的胆量。那些对话是什么样的，去说，我要做这个？是的。好吧，说实话，我决定开自己的餐馆的主要原因是，如果我以传统方式去做，我永远不会有自己的餐馆。
if I did it in a traditional way. Right. At all. There was just no way. What would the traditional way be? So, you know, I opened up in 2004 and I was still working for Dania Belude Cafe Belude in 2003. And, you know, I had cooked professionally for about four plus years. Not enough,
根本不会。根本没有办法。什么是传统方式？所以，你知道，我在2004年开业，2003年我还在为Dania Belude的Cafe Belude工作。而且，你知道，我专业烹饪了四年多。不够，
but I had, you know, traveled around seeing a lot of different things, worked abroad and if you wanted to open up your own restaurant back then, which wasn't that long ago, you had to be a patron to the restaurant and know the chef and say, hey, I'm moving back to Minnesota.
但我，你知道，到处旅行，看到了很多不同的东西，在国外工作过，如果你在那个时候想开自己的餐馆，那其实没过多久，你必须是餐馆的常客，认识厨师，然后说，嘿，我要搬回明尼苏达州了。
I want to open up a restaurant. Do you have a chef that you could like give me? And that's how, like, most people, most chefs got their own restaurants as a, you know, through someone they knew. No one was like, I'm going to open up my own restaurant. That almost never happened. And I'm
我想开一家餐馆。你有可以给我的厨师吗？这就是大多数人，大多数厨师通过他们认识的人获得自己餐馆的方式。没有人会说，我要开自己的餐馆。那几乎从未发生过。而且我
a relatively competitive person. I looked at the kitchen where I was at. I said, oh, I was probably 13 out of, you know, 13 in the progression of maybe I'll get my own kitchen. And I was like, I can't do this. I got to find a different way. And one of the things that I learned when I was living in Japan was,
是一个相对有竞争力的人。我看着我所在的厨房。我说，哦，我可能在13个人里排第13，也许我会拥有自己的厨房。我就想，我做不到。我得找到一种不同的方式。我在日本生活时学到的事情之一是，
you know, food didn't have to be super expensive to be good. And I just want to do something different. So I decided not to open up a French fancy restaurant and do something different. And that's why if I was better, truthfully, I probably
你知道，食物不需要非常昂贵也能很好吃。我只是想做一些不同的事情。所以我决定不开一家法式高级餐馆，而是做一些不同的事情。这就是为什么如果我更好，说实话，我可能
would never open up Momofuku. But you've talked about it before. You were kind of over fancy restaurants. You were kind of, you kind of had enough. Is that true? Yeah. I mean, I worked at most, if you ask a lot of people back then, they worked at fancy restaurants, not they cared about the food, per se, or the
永远不会开Momofuku。但你以前谈到过。你当时有点厌倦了高级餐馆。你有点，你有点受够了。是真的吗？是的。我是说，我在大多数地方工作过，如果你问当时很多人，他们在高级餐馆工作，不是因为他们关心食物本身，或者
clientele. It was the only place you could work with the best ingredients and learn the best techniques. So in some ways, you know, I got tired. I remember coming back and it was a lot of culture shock for me moving back to America and then being on the
客户。那是你唯一能用最好的食材和学习最好技术的地方。所以在某些方面，你知道，我累了。我记得回来时，搬回美国对我来说有很多文化冲击，然后在上东区，不得不，你知道，把沙拉切得更碎，所有东西酱汁放在一边，定制，你知道，为所有这些人制作一切。所以杰森在那里吃过？是的。是的。是的。杰森·贝特曼在烹饪界很有名，被认为是最难伺候的人之一。
Upper East Side and having to, you know, chop a salad even more and everything sauce on the side and custom, you know, making everything for all of these. So Jason ate there? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Jason Bateman is well known in the culinary world as being one of the most difficult people to cook for.
我让服务员搬把椅子过来。而且，我很高兴你提到这一点，杰森绝对是对此有罪的人。但作为一个加拿大人，我第一次我没有经历过那种要求
I have the waiter pull up a chair. And this, I'm glad that you touch on this and Jason is definitely somebody who's guilty of this. But as a Canadian, the first time I I didn't experience that kind of like asking
特殊东西的情况，直到我来到这个国家。首先，我从不那样做。我是我的梅格·瑞恩。可怜的梅格·瑞恩。现在她和你属于同一类了。我是说萨莉，哈利遇上萨莉。没有那种著名的
for special stuff until I came to this country. First of all, I never do that. I'm one of my Meg Ryan. Poor Meg Ryan. Now she's in the same category as you. I mean Sally, Harry McSally. Isn't there a famous sort of
这个？我要她点的那个。对任何人都没有区别。是的，她非常挑剔。但我喜欢那个。我喜欢她点的那个。那太棒了。但那一幕发生了什么？我不知道这个参考。但那种人们去说，嗯，是的。而且我记得像第一次和某人在一起时，他们像
this? I'll have what she's having. No difference to anyone. Yeah, she was very picky. But I love that. I love what she's having. That's great. But what happens in that scene? I don't know the reference. But that idea of people going like, um, yes. And I remember like seeing some being with somebody the first time they like
把食物退回去。我太尴尬了。我当时想，天哪。而且不是因为像它有什么问题。而是因为它只是不是他们想要的方式。是的。我会做的是，如果食物上来时不热，对我来说，它感觉
sent food back. I was so embarrassed. I was like, Jesus Christ. And it wasn't because like there was something wrong with it. It was like it just wasn't the way they wanted it. Yeah. What I will do is if food shows up not hot I for me, it feels
好像味道没那么浓郁。所以即使是寿司。是的。我会要求服务员看看他们能不能把它在灯下放久一点或者什么的。不管怎样，不管发生什么。他们就是那样煮的。他们只是用灯煮它。
like it doesn't taste as flavorful. And so I will even sushi. Yeah. I will ask the waiter to to see if they can throw it under the light longer or whatever. However, whatever happens. That's how they cook it. They just cook it with light.
因为我想厨师希望食物充满味道，它越冷，味道就越淡。还是我疯了？不，不，你是绝对正确的。热食应该热着上。冷食应该冷着上。如果你去一家餐馆，他们端上来的东西是
Because I figured that the chef wants the food to be bursting with flavor and the colder it gets, the more muted the flavor gets. Or am I crazy? No, no, you're absolutely right. Hot food is supposed to be served hot. Cold food is supposed to be served cold. And if you go to a restaurant and you serve something that is
冷的，而它应该是热的，你有权把它退回去。因为我想可能是服务员太忙了，或者厨师不想让它保持那个温度。所以，是的，不管怎样。但问题是，在大多数餐馆里，当食物到达某种组织时，它被称为传菜口
cold and it should be hot you have every right to send it back. Because I figured it's probably the waiter was too busy or the chef didn't want it at that temperature. So, yeah, anyway. But the thing is it's called a pass in most restaurants when the food hits sort of the organization
在它送到餐厅之前。到那时可能会出很多乱子。是的。当然，让我问你这个，因为你提到了。我一直想知道，这感觉像，这是一个神话吗？我们都做过。有人对服务员粗鲁什么的，然后你去想，哦，你被
before it goes right out to the dining room. So much shit can go wrong by that time. Yeah. Of course, let me ask you this because you brought this up. I've always wanted to know and this feel like, is this a myth? We've all done it before. Somebody's like root to the waiter or whatever and you go like, oh, you're
保证了。他们退回了什么东西吗？是的，你保证整个厨房现在都要往你的汤里吐口水什么的。在不透露任何名字的情况下，你见过这种情况吗？不，不，不，不。我是说，听着，这太搞笑了。你知道，我看了那部电影《等待》，我想很多厨师
guaranteed. Are they sent something back? Yeah, you're guaranteed for the whole kitchen's going to spit in your soup now or whatever. Without divulging any names, have you ever seen that happen? No, no, no, no. I mean, listen, it's hilarious. You know, I watched that movie waiting and I think a lot of people that are cooks
看那部电影是因为它就像我们希望我们能做的事情，但那是从来没有人见过的。太棒了。所以我们现在可以把那个放下。我是说，人们会一直在背后说顾客的坏话吗？是的。等等，什么？是的。我是说，
watch that movie because it's like something we wish we could do, but that's never anything anyone's ever seen. Great. So we can lay that to rest now. I mean, do people shit talk customers behind their back all the time? Yeah. Wait what? Yeah. I mean,
不，但我是说，如果有人退回一份菜要加热，那是常见的事情吗？还是我应该像我做的时候那样感到羞愧？这并不常见。唯一的问题是当顾客错了的时候，对吧？对。
no, but I mean, if somebody sends a sense, Jason Bateman is out there. If somebody sends a plate back to be reheated, is that a common thing or should I be as mortified as I feel when I do do it? Which is not often. The only time it's a problem is when the customer's wrong, right? Right.
对。就像，这经常发生。比如，哦，我觉得这瓶酒塞子坏了，但它没坏，对吧？或者这块牛排应该是三分熟的，但它不是。顾客其实是错的，对吧？而且我觉得多年来，即使顾客错了，餐馆也只能
Right. Like, it happens all the time. Like, for example, oh, I think this bottle of wine is corked and it's not corked, right? Or this steak should be rare and it's not. The customer's actually wrong, right? And I think for years, even if the customer is wrong, the restaurant just sort of had
忍气吞声。我决定我不再那样做了。我会告诉顾客，不，你错了。不错。不错。我觉得我把我们带偏了，让戴维为餐馆业辩护，还有那些尖叫的人，比如，该死的杰森·贝特曼的牛排显然
to eat shit. And I sort of decided I was no longer going to do that. I would tell the customer, no, you're wrong. Nice. Nice. I feel like I took us off on a tangent here and making David defend the restaurant industry and the people who are screaming like, fucking Jason Bateman's tail apparently
不够热。你把戴维和我带进了你的生活。但我想要，我确实想回到你说的某件事上。不，我只是想说，好吧，他是我的嘉宾，我想这次和戴维拥抱一下。我太兴奋了。我只有三个问题。别把它们都用完了。让我说这个。
isn't hot enough. You took David and me down in your life. But I want I do want to get back to something you said. No, I just wanted to say, well, he's my guest and I want to hug this time with David. I'm so excited. I've only got three questions. Don't wear them all out. Let me say this.
你谈到了竞争，当你开始经营餐馆时，你不是很多人知道这一点。我不认为你小时候是个高尔夫神童。是的，那样想很奇怪。我是说，因为显然我从来没有成为一名高尔夫球手，但我爸爸
You talked about being competitive and when you started the restaurant you were not a lot of people know this. I don't think that you were a golf prodigy as a kid. Yeah, it's weird to think about it that way. I mean, because obviously I never panned out as a golfer, but my dad
远超他的时代。现在如果你去高尔夫球场或高尔夫锦标赛，你会看到成吨的亚洲孩子被他们的父母大声呵斥。我爸爸就是那个原始的亚洲爸爸，大声呵斥他的儿子在高尔夫上要更好。哇。你知道，威尔刚刚让我重新沉迷于高尔夫，我每天都打
was way ahead of his time. Now if you go to the golf course or golf tournaments, you're going to see tons of Asian kids with their parents yelling at them. My dad was the OG Asian dad yelling at his son to be better at golf. Wow. You know, Will just got me re-addicted to golf and I played every
过去一个月。整个采访现在要变成高尔夫了。听着。那时候打高尔夫太不酷了。提醒你，像没有人。现在也不怎么酷。现在也不怎么酷。但我精疲力竭了。我年纪轻轻就精疲力竭了。我是说，我赢了很多锦标赛
day for the last month. This whole interview is now going to go to golf. Listen. It was so uncool to play golf back then. Mind you, like no one. It's not that cool now either. It's not that cool now. But I burned out. I burned out really young. I mean, I won a bunch of tournaments
然后有个叫泰格·伍兹和菲尔·米克尔森的孩子。他们也比其他所有人都好一点。不可能。所以你当时在洛杉矶？不，我是在。我在北弗吉尼亚长大，但我记得试图参加休斯顿那个叫“大眼睛”的锦标赛的资格赛。
and there was this kid named Tiger Woods and Phil Nicholson. They were a little bit better than everybody else too. No way. So you were here in Los Angeles? No, I was. I grew up in Northern Virginia, but I remember trying to qualify for this tournament called The Big Eye in Houston.
我从来没获得资格，但有三年，有个比我大一两岁的孩子在小册子的封面上。我当时想，我他妈怎么可能打败这家伙？他当时比所有人都好得多。那是泰格吗？是的。所以你是加号还是平标准杆？我是，取决于高尔夫球场，
And I never qualified, but for three years there was this kid that was a year or two older than me that was on the cover of the pamphlet. And I was like, how the fuck am I ever going to beat this guy? He's so much better than everybody back then. That was Tiger? Yeah. And so were you a plus or were you a scratch? I was, depending on the golf course,
我的主场高尔夫俱乐部，我是平标准杆。天哪。那现在呢？我最后一次认真打高尔夫球是在2003年，我把我的高尔夫球杆扔进了爱尔兰Old Head的海洋里。
my home golf club, I was a scratch. Good God. And what about now? The last time I played around a golf seriously was 2003 and I threw my golf clubs into the ocean at Old Head in Ireland.
第18洞是一个俯瞰海洋的雄伟东西，我当时真的在想，也许我可以练习并尝试参加巡回赛什么的。你多大？我不知道。我可能大概25、26岁，因为我爸爸一直说，哦，你有所有这些天赋，但我从来没有头脑游戏，因为我只是个疯子。而且你知道，关于爱尔兰的事情是他们没有很多练习场。所以你就像冷着去那里。需要四个洞才能弄清楚你的挥杆。我真的打出了四柏忌小鸟球，这是我打过的最
And the 18th hole is this majestic thing overlooking the ocean and I literally was thinking to myself maybe I could practice and try for the tour or something like that. How old were you? I don't know. I was probably like 25, 26, because my dad has always said, oh, you have all these natural
精神分裂的一轮。听起来像我的比赛，对吧？除了小鸟球。所以我说，去他妈的，我再也不玩这个了。我把我的球杆扔进了海里。我爸爸对我大喊大叫，我说，爸爸，我是为那些高尔夫球杆付钱的。所以你从那以后就没打过？我去年夏天打过一次
gifts, but I never had the head game because I just was a basket case. And you know, the thing about Ireland is they don't have a lot of practice ranges. So you just like go there cold. Takes you four holes to figure out your swing. And I literally had like a quadruple bogey birdie and it was the most
那是一次，我可能不会再打了。你会打出90多杆吗？我打出了我想大概88杆。好吧，戴维，对于一个真正有工作且从不打球的人来说，这完全没问题。我只是
schizophrenic round I've ever played. That sounds like my game, right? Except for the birdies. So I said, fuck this, I'm never going to play this ever again. I chucked my clubs in the ocean. My dad yelled at me and I was like, dad, I played for those golf clubs. So you have not played since? I played once last summer
高尔夫根本带给我任何快乐。我只是，我必须。哇。我是说，我是那种性格，上瘾的性格，如果我有机会，即使我不喜欢玩这个游戏，我也会整天玩和练习，成为每年赢得俱乐部锦标赛的那个混蛋。
and that was a I probably won't play again. Would you shoot something in the 90s? I shot like I think like an 88. Well, David, that's totally fine for a guy who's actually got a job and who never plays. I'm just the
是的。没有人喜欢那个家伙。对。不，我离为什么你坚持了那么久太近了，只是因为你有天赋。不，我怕我爸爸，父亲，对吧？怕我爸爸。是的。好的。好的。
golf does not bring me any joy whatsoever. I just I have to. Wow. I mean, I'm that kind of personality, addictive personality where if I had the chance, even though I don't like playing the game, I would play and practice all day to be that asshole that wins the club championship every year.
但一个好的激励者，他确实在你身上培养了一些好的工作习惯，对吧？还有对卓越和胜利的渴望，所有这些东西，你把它指向了餐馆。好吧，我是说，它变得有点病态了，对吧？那种需要更努力工作，变得
Yeah. Nobody likes that guy. Right. No, I got a danger too close to why did you stick with it for so long just because you had a gift for it. No, I'm scared of my dad father, right? Scared of my dad. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
更好，练习更多。是的。但我说，但你，但这就是我提到它的原因。你可以在你的工作和动力中看到它。就像你有，你非常专注，即使你做很多事情，你的专注需要你看向很多方向。
But a good motivator, he put in some good work habits with you, right? And some thirst for excellence and winning and all that stuff and you pointed it towards restaurants. Well, I mean, it sort of became pathological, right? Of like the need to work harder, be
你仍然同时驾驭很多东西，这并不容易做到。你知道，这是很多餐馆，很多企业。这需要很大的决心和很多，你知道，纪律，坦率地说。我很幸运，我被包围着，如果这不是我表现得
better, practice more. Yeah. But I say, but you but that's why I brought it up. You can see it in your in your work and your drive. Like you have you're very focused, even though you do a lot of your focus requires you to look in a lot of directions.
谦虚，我只是有非常棒的人。我因为所有发生的事情得到了太多的赞誉。而且我甚至不再在餐馆里真正做饭了。所以，你知道，我只是，我不知道。当我回顾发生的一切时，我很难相信我们做了所有这些，
You still harness a lot of stuff at the same time, which is not easy to do. You know, it's a lot of restaurants, a lot of businesses. It takes a lot of determination and a lot of, you know, discipline, frankly. I've been lucky and I've been surrounded by and if this is not me being
你知道。是的。嘿，所以关于烹饪，你知道，成为最好的厨师或最好的厨师之一需要什么？显然，你需要有很好的品味。没有双关语的意思。你有没有注意到你在
modest, I just have really great people. I got way too much credit for all the things that happen. And I don't even cook in the restaurants really anymore. So, you know, I just, I don't know. And when I look back at everything that's happened, it's hard for me to believe that we did all that,
一个国家比另一个国家是更好的厨师，基于你喜欢烹饪的方式？是的。那有意义吗？不，确实有意义，而且正是那样。每个国家，我甚至不会说世界上的每个国家，即使是美国的各个地方也非常不同，对吧？比如
you know. Yeah. Hey, so on cooking on, you know, what does it take to be the best chef or one of the best? Obviously, you need to have great taste. No pun intended. Have you noticed that you are a better chef in
就盐而言，例如在多伦多，我觉得人们希望他们的食物里盐少一点。纽约总是希望他们的食物里盐多一点。而在日本，你以为有那么多酱油，会很咸。不，他们希望在很多食物里盐保持在最低限度。那不是
one country versus another country based on how you like to cook? Yeah. Does that make sense? No, it does make sense and it's exactly that. Every country, and I wouldn't even say every country around the world, even places in America are very different, right? Like
说拉面什么的。但在烹饪和技术方面，我认为在美国肯定是有益的，因为它是不同移民和不同技术的融合。所以如果你说，你知道，
just for salt, for example, in Toronto, I feel that people want less salt in their food. New York always wants more salt in their food. And in Japan, you think with all the soy sauce, it'd be very salty. No, they want it sort of at their minimum salt in a lot of the food. That's
或者在意大利米兰或佛罗伦萨的厨师，很难了解世界，因为你只做意大利菜。对。对。这既是一个好处，同时也是一个负面因素。你有没有注意到哪个城市或哪个地区，哪个区域
not say ramen or something like that. But in terms of the cuisine and the technique, it's certainly beneficial, I think, to be in America where it is sort of this amalgamation of different immigrants and different techniques. So if you say, you know,
有更多的需求和更多的健康食材？比如你能确定吗？有没有客户群看起来比其他地方更想要精简的东西？肯定的。我认为这取决于
or chef in Milan or Florence, Italy, it's hard to know the world because you're only cooking Italian food. Right. Right. And that is a benefit and sort of a negative simultaneously. Have you noticed what city or what area, what region
顾客，比如去SoulCycle的人，你知道他们会，我是说，你几乎可以为他们量身定做菜单。对。人们会喜欢的食物类型的定型。肯定的。是的。洛杉矶有趣的是，你以为人们吃得更健康。他们
is more demands and more sort of healthier ingredients? Like can you actually determine that? Is there a clientele that seems like it wants something more stripped down than other places? For sure. I think it depends on
确实。他们吃健康的午餐。我发现很多人不吃早餐，晚餐吃得像屎一样，还有拼车。对。人们现在他妈的喝得烂醉。是的。是的。他们以前不这样。你是对的。不。是的。这对
the customer, like the people that go to SoulCycle, you know that they're going to, I mean, you can almost like make a menu exactly for them. Right. The type casting of the kinds of food that people are going to like. For sure. Yeah. The funny thing with LA, you think people eat healthier. They
餐馆来说很棒。你知道，当你看到像，我曾经有位医生，当我在酒吧看到他时，他在抽烟，我觉得那是我见过的最疯狂的事情。医生抽烟。当我看到你或某些节目上的厨师吃任何他们想吃的东西时，我就想，是的
do. They eat healthy lunches. I find that a lot of people skip breakfast and they eat like total shit for dinner and with ride sharing. Right. People get fucking shit-faced now. Yeah. Yeah. Where they didn't use to. You're right. No. Yeah. It's been great for
因为我喜欢食物的是每个人对它都有不同的关系。对。每个人都在不断地思考它，比如，我应该多吃这个，少吃这个，以及吃你知道对你很糟糕但味道很好的东西所带来的内疚感。比如我们应该听多少或听多少
restaurants. You know, when you see like, I had this doctor once when I saw him at this bar and he was smoking and I thought that was the craziest thing I've ever seen. A doctor smoking. And when I've seen you or chefs on certain shows just eating literally anything they want, I was like, yeah
那个内疚感，或者你听那个内疚感有多少或多少，因为派对感觉像我想要我想要的，因为它取悦我，然而我知道取悦我的东西对我的身体不好，所以我吃了它，但我很痛苦。你知道我的意思吗？对。你知道，我觉得像大多数事情一样，当你年轻的时候，你可以吃
because what I love about food is everyone has a different relationship to it. Right. Everyone is constantly thinking about it and like, should I eat more of this, less of this and the guilt associated with eating something you know is horrible for you, but tastes great. Like how much or how little should we listen to
任何东西，我记得第一次尝到像鹅肝酱之类的东西，那只是脂肪。是的。但它太好吃了，但在某个时候，这一切都会追上你，我发现厨师年纪越大，他们就越不想吃他们自己做的东西。哦，真的吗？
that guilt or how much or how little do you listen to that guilt because party feels like I want what I want because it pleases me however I know that what pleases me isn't good for my body therefore I eat it but I'm miserable. You know what I mean? Right. You know, I think like most things when you're younger you can sort of eat
是的。回到拼车的事情，你有没有注意到在洛杉矶，自从Uber和Lyft以及所有这些东西出现以来，餐馆生意增加了，如果不是因为别的，只是因为酒精消费可以发生，比如在纽约，我想象人们多年来会通过酒精赚钱
anything and I remember first tasting like foie gras or something like that which is just fat. Yeah. But it's so good but at some point it all catches up with you and I find that the older chefs get the less they want to eat the stuff that they actually make. Oh really?
因为你跳上一辆出租车，但在洛杉矶，你总是必须考虑到回家的长途驾驶，现在不用了。钱增加了吗？我是说，是的，在COVID之前，100%，这对行业来说是一个真正的福音，因为这就是你真正赚钱的方式
Yeah. Getting back to the ride sharing thing have you noticed that in Los Angeles since Uber and Lyft and all that stuff came into play that the restaurant business increased because if for no other reason just the alcohol consumption could happen like in New York I would imagine people would make money on alcohol
在任何餐馆生意中，饮料，你知道，一瓶酒或几杯鸡尾酒加起来，再说一次，如果你在洛杉矶吃饭，在拼车之前，大多数人不会沉溺于第二、第三或第四杯饮料
for years because you're jumping in a cab but in LA you always have to factor in that long drive home now no longer. Has the money gone up? I mean yes before COVID 100% and that was a real boon for the industry because that's how you make money really
他们可能喝一杯，就这样。你提到了COVID，它是什么？是的，我猜它是什么，抱歉，让我写下笔记。不，像面条店？只是显然COVID已经
in any kind of restaurant business as beverages and you know bottle of wine or several cocktails adds up and again if you are eating in LA more often than not before ride sharing most people wouldn't indulge with that second third or fourth drink
完全改变了，不仅是餐馆，还有经济以及我们做所有事情的方式。你认为COVID之后餐馆的未来会是什么样？你有什么预测吗？是的，我有，而且它没有，它不是一个好的预测。我刚刚和吉利布兰德参议员谈过
they'd have maybe one and that would be it. You brought up COVID What is it? Yeah I guess what is it sorry let me just write notes. No like a noodles place? Just the Obviously COVID has
对一群，我甚至不知道Zoom通话上到底是谁，但我从三月份就开始说这个了，而且这不是一个受欢迎的观点，我希望我不是对的，但我说我认为90%的所有独立餐馆如果没有政府的干预将会倒闭，而且我认为我是对的，我想也许是
completely changed not just restaurants but the economy and how we do everything What do you think the future of restaurants is going to be post-COVID? Do you have a prediction? Yeah I do and it has it's not a good one. I just spoke with Senator Gillibrand
85% 90%。这是因为入住限制吗？是的，我是说，这是25%，取决于像纽约是25%室内，拉斯维加斯说是50%，我想加州仍然是25%。一切都一样。经济仍然一样
to a bunch of I don't even know who the hell was on the zoom call but I've been saying this since March and it has not been a popular take and I wish I wasn't right but I said I think that 90% of all independent restaurants will close without intervention from the government and I think I'm right I think maybe it's
固定成本没有改变，而且我会告诉你，如果你的餐馆不是100%入住率，你就在赔钱。我听到汤姆·克里奇奥在比尔·马赫秀上提到过这种事情，汤姆建议像他有一个关于为什么
85% 90% Is that because the occupancy limitations? Yeah I mean it's 25% depending on like New York is 25% indoors Las Vegas is say 50% I think California is 25% still. Everything's the same. The economics are still the same
当这发生时，当这场大流行发生时，政府为什么不利用所有的餐馆生意来喂养人们，从而保持餐馆生意，经济以那种方式运行，当农场和牛奶有所有这些短缺时
the fixed costs haven't changed and I'll tell you if you're not 100% occupancy for a restaurant you're losing money. I heard Tom Clicchio say this kind of pitched this thing on the Bill Mar Show Tom had suggested like he had this whole idea of why
以及农产品和肉类，我觉得这是一个好主意。不，这是一个肯定被提出来的想法，政府，不奇怪，他们决定不这样做，因为肖恩，别生气，我觉得这是一个真正的机会
when this happened, when this pandemic happened didn't the government utilize all the restaurant businesses to feed people to then keep the restaurant businesses the economy going that way when there's all these shortages at farms and with milk
我觉得你可以让苏西在2020年做酱汁，并得到政府的补贴来做社区需要的事情，但这并没有发生。我一直想问像你这样一位非常有成就的厨师，我们一直想知道
and produce and meats I thought it was a great idea. No it's an idea that was certainly floated and the government not a surprise they decided not to do it because Sean don't get pissed off I thought this was a real opportunity
你吃什么，你喜欢什么，因为这些家伙知道我真的会为免费的奶昔或饼干做任何人想要的任何事情，如果你必须吃同样的东西或饼干蛋糕或同样的东西一个星期，那会是什么
I thought you could have had Susie the Sausier in 2020 and getting subsidized by the government to do something that communities needed and it just hasn't happened. I always wanted to ask somebody like you an incredibly accomplished chef we always want to know
你的糖是什么，如果你必须选择，甜甜圈块同样的东西一个星期，我不知道伙计，好吧，那就算了，我可能会选择炸鸡，抱歉戴维，你应该知道他问的原因
what you eat and what you like because these guys know that I'd literally do anything anybody wanted for a free milkshake or a cookie and if you had to eat the same thing or a cookie cake or the same thing for a week what would it be
是因为他确实每天午餐吃一个金枪鱼三明治配原味薯片，那是真的吗？在纸盘子上几乎每天，或者花生酱三明治，等等，告诉我这个金枪鱼三明治，你是自己做这个金枪鱼三明治，还是从熟食店买的
what is your sugar if you had to pick how about a donut chunk same thing for one week I don't know man okay then forget that I'd probably choose fried chicken sorry David you should know the reason he's asking
好问题，两者都有，但我大部分时间都是自己做，我只是把金枪鱼，罐装金枪鱼，你用的是哪种金枪鱼，泉水还是橄榄油，水，没有油，没有油，那不是一件好事，第一，你输了，那很恶心，你什么意思，不，因为
is because he quite literally eats a tuna sandwich with plain chips every day for lunch is that real? on a paper plate almost every day or a peanut butter sandwich wait tell me about this tuna sandwich are you making this tuna sandwich yourself or are you buying it from like a deli
我在里面放了蛋黄酱和芹菜，就这样，是的，但即使如此，泉水金枪鱼，那，拜托，你得改变它，让我问你这个，金枪鱼里的汞太多了吗？我不知道那个答案，好吧，那我们得走，等等，等等，像带我们走一遍，肖恩，这是一个很好的台词
great question both but I make it most of the time I just put the tuna the canned tuna what kind of tuna are you using spring water or olive oil water no oil no oil that's not a good thing number one you lose there that's gross what do you mean no because
因为戴维想知道，因为戴维，这是他的领域，所以你就像斯科蒂，我要做点午餐，所以你溜进厨房，溜溜，嗯，抱歉
I put mayonnaise in it and celery and that's it yeah but even still spring water tuna that's come on you got to change it let me ask you this is there too much mercury in tuna I don't know that answer well then we got to go wait wait wait like walk us through it Sean this is a great line
然后你就像，有人把该死的WD-40拿进来，该死的壁橱还在吱吱作响，所以你拿出一罐金枪鱼，你有什么，你通常做两颗星，是的，咀嚼罐，好吧，因为你可能锻炼很多
cause David wants to know cause David this is his area of it so you're like Scotty I'm going to make some lunch and so you slip slip slip into the into the kitchen slipper slipper huh sorry
所以你有两罐，你有两罐星吻金枪鱼，是的，和水，然后你做那个事情，你只是用手，你没有那种自动的，不，这是一个手动的，这是一个奇迹鞭子，带出最好的食物
and you're like somebody get some fucking WD-40 in here the fucking closet is still creaking so then you take out a can of tuna what do you got you got the I usually do two star kiss yeah chewed cans well cause you're exercising a lot probably
带出最好的食物，我们不需要叮当声，只需要品牌最好的食物蛋黄酱，多少蛋黄酱，多少蛋黄酱，所有你能处理的，这是我到目前为止听到的唯一好的东西，好的，还有芹菜，我必须和芹菜一起吃
so you've got the two cans you got the two cans of star kiss tuna yeah and water and then you do the thing and you just by hand you don't have one of those automatic no it's a hand thing it's a miracle whip to bring out the best foods
质地，现在看，但现在一位伟大的厨师会考虑那些芹菜切块的大小会是多少，对吧戴维，对吧杰森，你非常准确，所以现在我们知道了这个，戴维，如果你如果想到你想做一个金枪鱼
and bring out the best best foods we don't need the jingle just the brand best foods mayonnaise how much mayonnaise how much mayonnaise all you can handle that's the only good thing I've heard so far okay and so and the celery and I have to eat it with celery
沙拉三明治，你会怎么做，而且真的，你会怎么让它不同，好吧，我不会用泉水里的金枪鱼，因为我觉得它太淡了，你到时候还不如喝一杯Soylent奶昔，我对此持开放态度，我是说，我只是觉得橄榄
texture now see but now a great chef will think about what the size of those celery cuts are going to be correct David correct Jason you are very accurate so now we know this David what would you do if you if it occurred to you that you wanted to make a tuna
油更好，味道更好，而且也有更好的罐装金枪鱼品牌，不要做一个完全他妈的势利小人，也有更好的罐装金枪鱼品牌，做一个势利小人，做一个势利小人，所以我可能会那样做，虽然在楼下我可能也有一些太阳吻，然后Sarcast
salad sandwich how would you go about it and for real how would you make it different well I wouldn't use tuna in spring water because I think it's just too bland you might as well eat a like drink a soylent shake at that point I am open to it I mean I just think the olive
你这里有两层楼的房子，还是地下室，是地下室，我丢了一些洋葱，比如我最后切碎了一些洋葱和一些芹菜，然后我可能会加一点柠檬汁，然后我放蛋黄酱，我不用最好的食物，我会用一种叫QP的蛋黄酱，它是来自日本的
oil is is better and better tasting and there's better brands not to be a total fucking snob there's better brands of canned tuna as well be a snob be a snob so I would I probably do that although downstairs I probably have some sun kissed as well and then sarcast
油越来越好，味道也越来越好，而且有更好的品牌，并不是说要当个彻头彻尾的势利眼，罐装金枪鱼也有更好的品牌，当个势利眼吧，当个势利眼吧，所以我可能会那样做，尽管楼下我可能也有一些Sunkist，还有沙丁鱼
you got a two-story house here or is it a basement is it a basement I've been lost some onions like I finally diced some onions and some celery and then I probably add a little bit more lemon juice and then I do mayonnaise I didn't use best foods I'd use a mayonnaise called QP which is from Japan
你这儿是两层楼的房子还是地下室？是地下室吗？我切了一些洋葱，把洋葱和芹菜切成细丁，然后我可能会多加一点柠檬汁，再加蛋黄酱，我没用Best Foods，我用的是一种叫丘比的蛋黄酱，是日本产的
and I do some salt and pepper and maybe a little bit of agave for sweetness to bring it out wow that's a whole new level of some sweetness now here is what kind of bread would you put it on David sorry just a we're gonna flash toast the bread yeah I would toast the bread a little bit maybe a multi-grain type
我会加点盐和胡椒，可能再加一点龙舌兰糖浆来提味，哇，这让甜味提升到了一个全新的高度，那么大卫，你会用什么样的面包来做呢？抱歉，我们得先把面包烤一下，对，我会稍微烤一下面包，也许用杂粮面包。
of sure yeah would you put butter on that on that toast shut the hell up unnecessary so David no Sean no David David this is my problem with cooking you've just described a 45-minute process
当然，你会往吐司上抹黄油吗？闭嘴吧，没必要，所以大卫，不，肖恩，不，大卫，大卫，这就是我在烹饪方面的问题，你刚才描述了一个45分钟的制作过程。
for a five-minute sandwich and that's why I don't cook well no that's why that's well that's not why main reason and then and then and then 20 minutes to clean everything I just said I can make it under five minutes wow see
就为了做一个五分钟的三明治，这就是我为什么不做饭的原因，不，那不是主要原因，而且还要花20分钟清理所有东西，我刚才说了，我可以在五分钟内做好，哇，你看。
so David I want to swing back I'm not a swinger swing back to what golf I want to I wanted to swing back to something you were talking about playing golf with your dad and your dad actually did your dad partner with you on one of your in your first restaurant
所以大卫，我想转回话题，我不是那个意思，转回高尔夫，我想转回你刚才提到的和你父亲一起打高尔夫的事，你父亲真的在你第一家餐厅里和你合伙了吗？
he did is that true yeah there was a lot of family drama going on and I obviously had a contentious relationship with my dad here we go let's tuck into this yeah I want to know that grab it you have any alcohol there David just start start sipping we're gonna get you crying in about 20 minutes he just
他确实合伙了，是真的吗？是的，当时家里有很多矛盾，我和我父亲的关系显然很紧张，开始了，我们深入聊聊这个，对，我想知道，大卫，你那儿有酒吗？开始喝吧，我们20分钟内就能让你哭出来，他只是。
he never said like I love you or anything very stern asian father and there was a lot of shit going on personally and in my family and is your dad still with us no he's not he passed away recently sorry about that I'm sorry it's all good and I remember
他从来没说过“我爱你”之类的话，是个非常严厉的亚洲父亲，当时无论是个人生活还是家庭内部都发生了很多烂事，你父亲还在世吗？不，他不在了，他最近去世了，很遗憾听到这个，我很抱歉，没关系，我记得。
being like a lot of my friends are going to graduate school and I was like fuck it I I saw how much money I might need to start this restaurant I was like it's cheaper than graduate school and then I would also remember being well if I'm 26 years old and I have to declare bankruptcy then that's not so bad
当时很多朋友都去读研究生了，我就想，去他的，我算了一下开这家餐厅需要多少钱，我觉得这比读研究生便宜，而且我还记得当时想，如果我26岁就破产了，那也没那么糟糕。
but you didn't lead with that with your conversation with your dad I think I did I said listen I'm I'm doing this with or without you and I'm going to raise the money I said you know and I think he offered and he and he got three of his friends and they pitched in a loan that I
但你和父亲谈话时没先提这个，我想我提了，我说听着，无论你是否支持，我都要做这件事，我会筹集资金，我说你知道，我想他主动提议了，他找了三个朋友，凑了一笔贷款，我。
paid back in two years 125 grand and I'm very fortunate very fortunate obviously but I even got to the point of thinking about doing crazier things like actually applying to school using the graduate like money loan and then bankroll in the school that way
两年内就还清了，125,000美元，我非常幸运，非常幸运，显然，但我甚至想过做更疯狂的事，比如申请学校，用研究生的贷款资金，然后用那笔钱来投资餐厅。
I was going to do something crazy that was a lot of pressure then to not only did you know that your dad specifically had his eye on you for excellence and you wanted to make him proud but now you're asking for his seed money as well that must have felt great to pay him back
我当时打算做些疯狂的事，那压力很大，不仅因为你知道你父亲特别看重你的卓越表现，你想让他骄傲，而且现在你还在向他要启动资金，还清那笔钱的感觉一定很棒。
and for him to have seen the incredible success you've had before he passed did he ever give it up to you about the success you know how he did it he told me a few years back stop working so hard did he really
在他去世前，他有没有看到你取得的巨大成功并认可你？你知道他是怎么做的吗？几年前他告诉我，别工作得那么辛苦了，真的吗？
wow that was his way do you have kids now I do I have a 19 month old and so wasn't the blessing in disguise to have a father like that so you can just shower your kid with tons and tons of love yeah it's been amazing I'm definitely the father that I'm not
哇，那是他的方式，你现在有孩子了吗？我有，我有一个19个月大的孩子，所以有一个那样的父亲是不是因祸得福？这样你就可以用大量的爱来浇灌你的孩子了，是的，这太棒了，我绝对是我父亲的反面。
what if you were like no I'm exactly the same way and I don't want to receive my kid you get into that fatherhood before in Ugly Delicious I think it's season 2 in the first episode when you find out the reveals that you and your wife are expecting a baby boy and
如果你说“不，我完全一样，我不想接受我的孩子”呢？你在《美食不美》里提到过为人父的事，我想是第二季第一集，当你发现你和妻子要迎来一个男婴时。
you really one of the great things about that show was it wasn't just about food it was about how food kind of connects us and how what food the role it's played in your life and how it's connected you to your family and was connecting you to your new family and I was really really moved
那个节目最棒的地方之一就是它不仅仅关于食物，它关于食物如何连接我们，食物在你生命中扮演的角色，以及它如何将你与家人连接起来，又如何连接你的新家庭，我真的被那一集深深打动了。
by that episode the way you talk to your mom and your sister and your mother-in-law and your wife and then you kind of go investigate other people and you talk to other restaurateurs about their relationship I forget that restaurant in Oregon your friend has that cool restaurant
你和你妈妈、姐姐、岳母以及妻子的交谈方式，然后你去调查其他人，和别的餐馆老板谈论他们的关系，我忘了俄勒冈那家餐馆的名字了，你朋友开的那家很酷的餐馆。
yeah Peter Peter's restaurant what's it called oh Kano Kano yeah and he lives there he lives on one side of the restaurant and then and it's kind of like there's just like a wall separating the kitchen and his kitchen and I just love the way that there are because I feel the same way that there is no division
是的，彼得，彼得的餐厅，叫什么来着？哦，Kano，对，Kano，他住在那里，他住在餐厅的一侧，厨房和他的厨房之间只有一堵墙，我真的很喜欢这种方式，因为我有同感，没有界限。
we can't put our lives into these different boxes it's all one big soup you know and nice these lives that we live thank you or stew mm-hmm better go I'm not married to a soup but I could go either way broth
我们不能把生活放进不同的盒子里，这就像一大锅汤，你知道，这些我们过的生活，谢谢，或者炖菜，嗯，更好，我不一定要嫁给汤，但我两者都能接受，肉汤。
broth is good yeah because broth cleaner yeah it's cleaner that's in your show too about how broth is like a such a huge but I just love the way that you broke that down that like it's all connected in the way that we live our lives and that we can't compartmentalize and that it's all just like this big
肉汤很好，是的，因为肉汤更清澈，对，更清澈，你的节目里也提到了肉汤是多么重要，但我真的很喜欢你拆解它的方式，即一切都是相连的，我们生活的方式，我们不能把生活割裂开来，这一切就像这大锅。
and I was really impressed with your connection to family and how important it was to you and I wonder now you know now meeting you because you were so nervous about becoming a dad and you're so honest about it and and I remember your mom saying that you were
我真的对你与家人的联系以及它对你的重要性印象深刻，现在见到你，因为你当时对成为父亲感到非常紧张，而且你对此非常诚实，我记得你妈妈说你。
going to be great parents she said your wife was going to be even better well yeah that's what she said the only reason I'd be a good parent was because of my wife yeah I know I remember I'm glad to say you're still mad about that but but did all your dreams come true did it happen the way you thought it would you know being a dad has been
会成为很棒的父母，她说你妻子会更好，嗯，是的，她是这么说的，我能成为好父母的唯一原因就是因为我妻子，是的，我知道，我记得，很高兴听到你还在为此生气，但你所有的梦想都实现了吗？事情如你所想的那样发生了吗？你知道，当父亲一直。
amazing and I think it's been the only highlight of quarantine because my son's not old enough to go to school and drive me crazy but being a dad has been amazing because all I did was work or go out and have just do whatever I wanted to do and I never intended
很棒，我认为这是隔离期间唯一的亮点，因为我儿子还没到上学让我抓狂的年纪，但当父亲真的很棒，因为我以前只知道工作，或者出去玩，做任何我想做的事，我从来没打算。
to think that I would ever have a family or I thought I'd just be a bachelor my entire life and still thinking about it or options always there but being a dad has caused me to being a husband has I think caused me and forced
想过我会拥有家庭，我以为我会一辈子做单身汉，还在考虑中，或者选择总是存在的，但成为父亲，成为丈夫，我认为已经促使我，强迫。
me not forced I think I've willingly tried to be better and to grow up I think it's taken me a long time to decide to grow up instead of being a fucking jerk yeah is that what made you nervous about the prospect of being a parent about the sort of responsibility that would immediately come
我，不是强迫，我想我是自愿尝试变得更好，去成长，我想我花了好长时间才决定长大，而不是做一个混蛋，是的，这就是让你对为人父的前景感到紧张的原因吗？关于那种随之而来的责任。
or was it more tied in to sort of like your experience as a child there was that you know I definitely didn't want to raise my future child the way I was raised but I wanted to be present I wanted to I didn't know how it would affect
还是更多地与你童年的经历有关？你知道，我绝对不想用我被抚养大的方式来抚养我未来的孩子，但我想要在场，我想要，我不知道这会如何影响。
how I worked right yeah and that was my big concern is how do I find a division between work and life and you know it's something I'm still trying to figure out yeah you know even when my son was born pre-COVID right I travel a lot right whether it's
我的工作方式，对吧，是的，那是我最大的担忧，我该如何在工作和生活之间找到平衡，你知道，这仍然是我在努力解决的问题，是的，你知道，即使在我儿子出生前，COVID之前，我也经常出差，对吧，无论是。
filming TV or the restaurants or whatever shit I gotta do I mean I think it's like probably five almost a little over five months a year I'm on the road and even when I am at home working you know it's I see you in the morning and I'll see you the next morning
拍摄电视节目还是餐厅，或者任何我必须做的事情，我的意思是，我想大概一年有五个月，甚至超过五个月，我都在路上，即使我在家工作，你知道，我早上见到你，然后第二天早上才能再见到你。
right you know and I think that's how a lot of my friends now in LA most of my friends in New York saw their kids you know they're with their nannies or somebody that's looking after the kids but their parents are working and you know I I just was like man I want to be a dad
对吧，你知道，我认为现在我在洛杉矶的很多朋友，我在纽约的大多数朋友，都是这样看他们的孩子的，你知道，他们和保姆在一起，或者有别人在照顾孩子，但他们的父母在工作，你知道，我当时就想，伙计，我想当个父亲。
that's literally my number one job I want to be good at is be a dad like that if you ask me what you care about the most obviously I want to make sure that I can financially take care of my family and the people that work for me and the company but I think overall my
那真的是我的头号工作，我想做好的就是当个父亲，如果你问我最在乎什么，显然我想确保我在经济上能照顾好我的家人，以及为我工作的人和公司，但我认为总的来说，我的。
priority when I found out my wife was pregnant was I want to be something that I think I'm going to be terrible at which is being a dad are you still enjoying the entrepreneurship of opening multiple restaurants like is it still excite you invigorate you get you out of the bed in the morning
优先级，当我发现我妻子怀孕时，就是我想成为一个我认为我会做得很糟糕的角色，那就是当父亲，你还在享受开设多家餐厅的创业过程吗？它还能让你兴奋、振奋，让你早上起床吗？
I mean yeah it changes it changes it's this post COVID world we'll see what happens right but two years ago I stepped down as CEO and we have other people in place for the culinary decisions if anything I feel like I'm just like a guidance
我的意思是，是的，它在改变，它在改变，这是COVID后的世界，我们走着瞧吧，对吧，但两年前我辞去了CEO的职务，我们在烹饪决策方面有其他人选，如果有的话，我觉得我只是一个指导。
counselor so I been focusing a lot more on media so I can it does sound lucrative though this is why we have the two-story house guys sorry keep going David it could be three good point so you know that's where I'm at is I don't know
顾问，所以我把更多的精力放在了媒体上，所以它可以，这听起来确实很赚钱，这就是为什么我们有两层楼的房子，伙计们，抱歉，继续说，大卫，可能是三层，好观点，所以你知道，这就是我的现状，我不知道。
you know we're facing some challenging times and I always say again I'm never going to do another restaurant and yet I always do another goddamn restaurant what would be the natural progression for somebody like yourself and to piggyback on that
你知道，我们正面临一些充满挑战的时期，我总是说，我再也不会开另一家餐厅了，然而我总是又开了一家该死的餐厅，对于像你这样的人来说，自然的职业发展会是什么？顺便问一下。
is there something else you want to you dreamed of doing ever you know I'm these are really hard-pressing questions for me right now well this is a tough listen we the hard one told me you guys would be the toughest smart we need an answer when we make
还有什么你想做的，你梦想做的事吗？你知道，这些对我来说现在是非常紧迫的问题，好吧，这是一个艰难的访谈，我们，那个难题，告诉我你们会是最难对付的，我们需要一个答案，当我们制作。
Leslie Stull look easy okay I'm out of here I think for me career-wise just like what I want to cook is very different and I'm trying to find some metaphor analogy but I just while I always care about
莱斯利·斯图尔看起来很容易，好吧，我走了，我想对我来说，在职业生涯方面，我想要烹饪的东西非常不同，我正在尝试寻找某种隐喻或类比，但我只是，虽然我一直关心。
eating in a fancy restaurant all these things like now I just want to cook or make things that are just wholesome and pure like a sandwich or piece of pizza I don't want the artist like a tuna sandwich even a tuna sandwich right I care more about not about winning awards or I just want to do
在高级餐厅吃饭，所有这些事情，现在我只想烹饪或制作一些纯粹、健康的东西，比如三明治或披萨，我不想像艺术家那样，比如金枪鱼三明治，甚至是金枪鱼三明治，对吧，我更在乎的不是赢得奖项，我只是想做。
that is good simple as that and I don't care about winning awards either that's why I never win him because I'm like you know what I don't want him currently the the big awards go to those places that design a plate that's almost doesn't even
那很好，就这么简单，我也不在乎赢得奖项，这就是为什么我从不获奖，因为我心想，你知道吗，我不想要它们，目前，大奖都颁给了那些设计出的菜品几乎看起来。
look like food right the artistry of it the way that it's all it's like an Oscar film you know like best picture there's a certain film you know that's not necessarily populist but it's it's complicated I get I think I've always wanted to be something that's populist but even still now I just would rather
都不像食物的地方，对吧，它的艺术性，它就像一部奥斯卡电影，你知道，比如最佳影片，你知道有些电影不一定是大众化的，但它很复杂，我想我一直想成为大众化的东西，但即便如此，现在我宁愿。
serve a bowl of chili yeah yeah I mean like that to me is more appealing both in taste and how someone might consume it you know you have a restaurant that's kind of lo-fi like that yeah but it's still not exactly where it could go and I don't even think it could be
端上一碗辣椒，是的，是的，我的意思是，对我来说，这在口味和人们消费的方式上都更具吸引力，你知道，你有一家餐厅，有点低保真，是那样吗？是的，但它仍然不是它最终可能去的地方，我甚至不认为它可能成为。
a restaurant right the kind of food that I personally the thing is I'm making more food now at home than ever before what about like a diner what do you do with your leftovers and just give me your address real quick give it outside I'd be good for leftovers David but my restaurants are hard
一家餐厅，对吧，我个人做的食物，问题是我现在在家做的食物比以往任何时候都多，那像餐馆呢？你如何处理剩菜？快把你的地址给我，我在外面，这对剩菜来说很好，大卫，但我的餐厅很难。
man yeah so damn hard where do you stand on design or do you just punt that to a partner I mean originally I didn't care about design or service it's true like if you talk to anybody about the restaurants our restaurants were like jail cells very minimal
伙计，是的，太难了，你在设计方面持什么立场？还是你直接把它交给合伙人？我的意思是，最初我不在乎设计或服务，这是真的，如果你和任何人谈论这些餐厅，我们的餐厅就像牢房，非常极简。
no comforts very loud music and very much in your face young and obnoxious and it was very punk rock in some ways without being punk right and I like the hard challenge and I wanted to win someone over with nothing but the food
没有舒适感，音乐声音很大，而且非常咄咄逼人，年轻又讨厌，在某些方面非常朋克，但又不是真正的朋克，我喜欢这种艰难的挑战，我想用纯粹的食物来赢得人心。
yeah going back to what I was at like is there something completely outside of the culinary world that you always dreamed of doing or you would want to kind of dabble in or Sean has it Sean has he has to ask that question I want to pitch you some ideas yeah he can't he can't not ask that
是的，回到我刚才说的，有没有什么完全在烹饪世界之外的事情是你一直梦想做的，或者你想涉足的？肖恩有，肖恩有，他必须问那个问题，我想向你推销一些想法，是的，他忍不住不问。
because I'm always interested in what other people are interested in other than the thing they're known for well I'm sort of doing that you know I I'm I'm like sort of trying to figure out what that is I'm still will always be related with food I think we're making a bunch of
因为我总是对人们除了他们成名的事情之外还对什么感兴趣很感兴趣，好吧，我正在做那件事，你知道，我正在尝试弄清楚那是什么，我想我永远会和食物有关，我想我们正在制作一堆。
consumer product goods like sauces and salts and stuff we're going to get into the hard goods business and part of this is how should I phrase this I like to do things that people think are stupid right or like it's not cool go on and if you ask a lot of guests or even
消费品，比如酱料、盐之类的，我们要进入硬商品业务，这部分是怎么说呢，我喜欢做人们认为愚蠢的事情，对吧，或者说它不酷，继续，如果你问很多客人，甚至。
like a younger version of me would you sell pots and pans or fucking a line of sauces I'd be like what a fucking sell out in some ways it's like how do you turn that yes it's maybe selling out but how do you make it awesome so you can put in the component of like Paul Newman where he
年轻版的我，你会卖锅碗瓢盆或者该死的酱料系列吗？我会说，真是个该死的卖国贼，在某些方面，它是如何转变的？是的，也许是卖国，但你如何让它变得很棒？这样你就可以加入像保罗·纽曼那样的成分，他。
sort of became somewhat philanthropic selling salad dressing money away listen let me just tell you this David there's no such thing as selling out there's only buying in okay full stop do you talk about
通过卖沙拉酱变得有点慈善，把钱捐出去，听着，让我告诉你，大卫，没有卖国这回事，只有买入，好吗，句号，你谈论。
all these places to go where do you like to go I mean all things being equal and you know without COVID etc when you're sitting at home and it's like you know you look at your watch and you look at your wife and you're like let's go I really want to have something that's satisfying and going to make me feel good where do
所有这些要去的地方，你喜欢去哪里？我的意思是，在所有条件相同的情况下，你知道，没有COVID等等，当你坐在家里，看着手表，看着你的妻子，心想，我们走吧，我真的很想吃点令人满足、让我感觉良好的东西，你去哪里。
you what's the first place you think of in New York it's a sushi restaurant called Shuko in downtown in like so the West Village it's so good okay you know it's different what streets it on I think it's like 12th Street between 5th and 6th or
你第一个想到的纽约地方是哪里？那是一家叫Shuko的寿司店，在市中心，西村，太棒了，好的，你知道，它很特别，在什么街上？我想是在第12街，第五大道和第六大道之间，或者。
Greenwich and Broadway what about Los Angeles we're in Los Angeles man that's the thing that LA there's so many places but really that arts district is sort of where the the newer spots are which is amazing to me the best you guys bobble hey Jason try to sound
格林威治大道和百老汇之间，那洛杉矶呢？我们在洛杉矶，伙计，这就是问题所在，洛杉矶有很多地方，但艺术区确实是新地点所在的地方，这对我来说太棒了，你们这些家伙，嘿，杰森，试着听起来。
older by the way yeah what is it no art district is where all the new kids me and the lady Jesus you know what just take yourself out to the shed and kill yourself I say I do not get out David what about this spago I've been hearing
更老一点，顺便说一句，是的，是什么？不，艺术区是所有新孩子所在的地方，我和女士，天哪，你知道吗，你自己去棚子里自杀吧，我说我出不去，大卫，那Spago呢？我听说过。
about there's so many good spots I went to once I'm not so he said we went and it's not cheap and it was it was us and it was Thoreau and she to Jones and we decided to play the credit card roulette and whoever lost had to pay for the meal and Thoreau lost
有很多好地方，我去过一次，我不，所以他说我们去了，那不便宜，是我们，还有梭罗和希托·琼斯，我们决定玩信用卡轮盘赌，谁输了谁就得付餐费，梭罗输了。
and he was so mad for real that he because he's and I'll say this he's so cheap and he it's just us talking it's just us talking he won't be right he didn't fucking listen to our show he cries when he orgasms too apparently
他非常生气，真的，因为他是，我会说这个，他太抠门了，这只是我们私下谈话，这只是我们私下谈话，他不会，他没听我们的节目，他高潮时也会哭，显然。
every time and I'm always there to wipe the tears it's weird remember when we can remember when we could go out and eat we're still recording can you just up the energy a little bit what about the tower bar
每次，我总是在那里帮他擦眼泪，真奇怪，还记得我们什么时候可以出去吃饭吗？我们还在录音，你能稍微提高一点能量吗？那塔楼酒吧呢？
what about the tower bar hey lady Sean can you pull the pamphlet into the frames so we can see the Scotty bring another pill in for you it's almost night night time it's five fingers of
那塔楼酒吧呢？嘿，女士，肖恩，你能把小册子拉进画面里吗？这样我们就能看到斯科蒂再给你拿一颗药，快到睡觉时间了，这是五指的。
chardonnay the pill and then he's out and a cup of tuna I can't wait I get excited around this time of day wait a second before we lose our shit the last thing David I want to ask you about your book can you talk a little bit about your new
霞多丽，药，然后他就睡着了，还有一杯金枪鱼，我等不及了，我每天这个时候都很兴奋，等一下，在我们崩溃之前，大卫，我想问你关于你的书，你能谈谈你的新书吗？
book yeah eat a peach great song yeah fuck man it's out it's a memoir you can read about my crazy life I don't even understand why it's out there I've been pretending that it didn't happen that's the easiest way
书，是的，《吃个桃子》，很棒的歌，去他的，伙计，它出版了，这是一本回忆录，你可以读读我疯狂的生活，我甚至不明白它为什么会出版，我一直假装它没发生过，这是最简单的方法。
for me to get through life it's so revelatory you're so open and honest in it so it's kind of like you have to pretend right that everybody's not reading about your what you're thinking about did you read it did you read it for an audio book I did
让我度过一生，它太具有启示性了，你在里面非常开放和诚实，所以这就像你必须假装，对吧，每个人都没有在读关于你的想法，你读了吗？你读了有声书吗？我读了。
I don't know that's why I was like your voice you guys are so good at doing this shit I don't know how it's I was of course I read all the criticism and first thing yeah he shouldn't have he shouldn't have read his own book never never read any criticism
我不知道，这就是为什么我说你的声音，你们真的很擅长做这些事，我不知道它是怎么，我当然读了所有的批评，第一件事，是的，他不应该，他不应该读他自己的书，永远不要读任何批评。
or reviews because if you believe the good ones you got to believe the bad ones too so are you like avoiding phone calls no no I mean it's it's been I think incredibly well received we were supposed to it was supposed to come out in May and we had like a 21
或评论，因为如果你相信好的，你也得相信坏的，所以你在躲避电话吗？不，不，我的意思是，我认为它非常受欢迎，我们本应该，它本应该在五月出版，我们有大概21个。
city book door so that's not happening but you know it's just weird because I don't know it's not only weird that the book is there it's weird that I'm such a competitive person and I'm like fuck you know I got to beat all these
城市的图书巡回宣传，所以那没发生，但你知道，这很奇怪，因为我不知道，不仅书在那里很奇怪，我是一个如此好胜的人也很奇怪，我心想，去他的，你知道，我得打败所有这些。
goddamn Trump books all order right now David listen we've taken up too much of your time already I can't thank you enough man I think you're such a cool dude and and you've done so many amazing things in you know I just wish you nothing but success
该死的特朗普的书，现在就订购，大卫，听着，我们已经占用你太多时间了，我怎么感谢你都不为过，伙计，我觉得你是个很酷的人，你做了这么多令人惊叹的事情，你知道，我只祝你成功。
and thanks for coming here and giving us your time I'm so glad I'm at you David I'm gonna make you a tuna fish sandwich now that's that's what I gotta do Sean I would love to see your version of that I would love by the way yes I would kill to taste that no I'm serious I'm going to we're gonna I'm gonna get you
谢谢你来到这里，抽出你的时间，我很高兴见到你，大卫，我现在要给你做一个金枪鱼三明治，这就是我必须做的，肖恩，我很想看看你的版本，顺便说一句，是的，我会为了尝尝那个而杀人，不，我是认真的，我要，我们要，我要拿到。
your info and I'm gonna make you something that hopefully you will enjoy I would kill for that that's so cool thank you David yeah leave it outside in the sun for a few hours and I'll pick it up I thank you for being with us thank you David thank you David see you later
你的信息，我会为你做一些希望你会喜欢的东西，我会为了那个而杀人，那太酷了，谢谢你，大卫，是的，把它留在外面的太阳下几个小时，我去取，谢谢你和我们在一起，谢谢你，大卫，谢谢你，大卫，回头见。
man thanks guys I feel like we have a good shot at getting a table inside of a week yeah instead of a week the three of us could call and say like Sean and Jason and we'll want to want to come in for for dinner and they want it to be gratis he literally just texted me
伙计，谢谢你们，我觉得我们很有机会在一周内订到桌子，是的，而不是一周，我们三个可以打电话说，肖恩和杰森，我们想来吃晚餐，他们想要免费的，他刚才给我发了短信。
right like we should because we're friends they'll probably throw in the desserts maybe right you think maybe you know me I don't like dessert you know how much I love dessert right I know angel I love it so much yeah I loved him though he was great he's uh
对，就像我们应该是朋友，他们可能会送甜点，对吧？你觉得也许，你知道我，我不喜欢甜点，你知道我有多爱甜点，对吧？我知道，天使，我太爱它了，是的，但我爱他，他很棒，他是，呃。
super normal yeah super normal and such a like huge family guy and really I implore our listener to watch second season of ugly delicious episode one and what he's really struggling with when he finds out that he's gonna have a kid it's it's such a beautiful kind of
超级正常，是的，超级正常，而且是一个非常顾家的人，真的，我恳请我们的听众观看《美食不美》第二季第一集，看看当他发现自己要有个孩子时，他真正挣扎的是什么，这是一种非常美丽的。
exploration of himself he's really honest about himself he's like I don't know if I'll be any good I think I'm gonna be a terrible dad he's really worried will you stop rolling up your sleeves yeah it's so gross why is just like pulling he's wearing a short-sleeve shirt he's just pulling up the sleeves and making it a tank top
自我探索，他对自己非常诚实，他说我不知道我是否会成为一个好父亲，我觉得我会成为一个糟糕的父亲，他真的很担心，你能别再卷起袖子了吗？是的，太恶心了，为什么，他穿着短袖衬衫，他只是把袖子卷起来，把它变成背心。
I don't want to look at your dumb guns how are they they're dumb are they not great well I guess they're good all right they're fine well we should probably go look at my noodles my forearm is bigger than my biceps what's wrong with me yeah so like a ramen noodle just like a really
我不想看你那愚蠢的肌肉，它们怎么了？它们很蠢，它们不是很好吗？好吧，我想它们很好，好吧，它们很好，好吧，我们可能应该去看看我的面条，我的前臂比我的二头肌还大，我怎么了？是的，就像拉面一样，就像一个真的。
take a photo of it insta he doesn't he doesn't insta he don't you don't have an instagram yet do you he does is he talking about take take an instant picture instagram like the polaroid well post take a picture of him post it to jason take it to the post office so long
拍张照片，Instagram，他不，他不玩Instagram，他没有，你还没有Instagram，对吧？他有，他在说拍一张即时照片，Instagram，像宝丽来，好吧，发布，拍一张他的照片，发布到杰森，把它带到邮局，太久了。
it's been let me just see how many steps I've got left because I did a lot of mailing already today I mailed my wife a letter she's right next to me but the journey was incredible I mailed her a letter every day to let her know I love her
已经很久了，让我看看我还剩多少步，因为我今天已经寄了很多信了，我给我妻子寄了一封信，她就在我旁边，但这段旅程太不可思议了，我每天都给她寄一封信，让她知道我爱她。
all right we should probably kick it we should wrap it up love David the other thing is bye bye smart less
好吧，我们可能应该结束了，爱大卫，另一件事是，再见，SmartLess。
smart less There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。